Mother Nature's laughing that's the
focus of tonight's angle
[Music]
last month was the hottest June on
record that heat then carried through
into July as a new record high global
average temperature was set on Monday
and then broken the very next day triple
digit heat index through the end of the
week
it's hard hard all right after all we're
in the middle of a season called summer
now fast forward a few years and imagine
that one morning you wake up to cook
breakfast you turn on the stove and the
gas doesn't work
and your living room is kind of cold so
you try to turn up the heat but the
thermostat won't go past 64.
then you're just so fed up you jump in
your car you drive to get gas because
the Tank's empty but every station you
pull into it's closed
then an emergency bulletin comes across
your cell phone saying that for the
foreseeable future Americans are
instructed to limit travel to home and
essential work maybe medical
appointments now why is this happening
because the UN has declared a global
climate emergency that's why I am
presenting a plan to supercharge efforts
to achieve this climate solidarity
backed through an all ends on Deck
acceleration agenda leaders of developed
countries must commit to reaching Net
Zero as close as possible to 2040. that
guy is Tony fauci of the climate issues
Net Zero by 2040 wait what's that I hear
hahaha
China's laughing yes it obviously would
never abide by any climate agreement
that slowed its growth but regardless
the U.N Secretary General Antonio
Gutierrez is undeterred in his plans to
set up a global climate body to force us
into compliance now much like we saw
during covid they plan to invoke
emergency Powers based on flimsy science
The Narrative is already being set the
hottest June ever recorded uh by a mile
we are walking on the hottest planet
ever watched the southwest and Florida
are bracing for more dangerous
record-breaking temperatures today there
were record-breaking temperatures
everywhere from China to Mexico but
scientists Warren this is only the
beginning as we see the growing impacts
of climate change
ah and justice during the pandemic we're
supposed to believe the science it's all
settled
the the the climate crisis is growing by
the day this will be the hottest June
and July it'll be the hottest summer
it'll be the hottest year and we all
know that because the science is telling
it to us and because Mother Earth is
responding by telling us exactly what's
going on
that's yours mind reader
it's my sweet creamy butter nope that's
chiffon margarine chiffon margarine oh
no it's my butter all right it's your
Fine Food even you mother nature it's
not nice to fool Mother Nature
and plants are moving forward for an
ultimate vote by 2024 that would
essentially give the UN control over
your lives it would mean less freedom
and less money for you and more power
for the government in this case a global
government
in September of 2024 right before our
presidential election the U.N will host
what's called a landmark Summit of the
future member nations are planning to
sign on to an agreement that will give
the Secretary General of the U.N
standing authority to convene and
operationalize automatically an
emergency platform in the event of a
future complex Global shock of
sufficient scale sufficient severity and
reach
now our friends over at the Federalist
are very smart to raise the red flag
here the so-called emergency platform
would give the UN the green light to
actively promote and drive an
international response that places the
principles of equity and solidarity at
the center of its work
well you know what that means watch your
wallet and hide your children
America will be footing the bill once
again as China skates along doing its
own thing
now the angle two years ago tried to
warn you that covet lockdown set the
predicate for more to come
their so-called Public Health experts
were wrong on everything from lockdowns
to masks to social distancing yet now we
see The Usual Suspects lining up to
exploit another hyped crisis of course
I'm talking about climate change that
was their kind of dry run for climate
lockdowns or whatever they're going to
do here
now in a few moments we're going to
explain today's climate alarmism is
based on a mountain of lies and bad
science again remember what the
scientists told us about covid and how
they ended up censoring opposing voices
same deal here so you should expect New
Waves of propaganda to wash over our
schools our news and our entertainment
all trying to convince you that if you
don't sacrifice your standard of living
now you're all going to burn up
whose side are you on Eddie what what
sides are there my nose
I'm gonna put a little of this aloe on
your back okay it should make you feel
better
we're not
but the only thing on fire here is their
pants because their policies would
amount to nothing more than a transfer
of wealth from our country to others who
didn't earn their way all in the name of
equity
if any of these people really really
cared about climate or climate change
they wouldn't be trying to so hard to
suck up to China which has zero
intention of phasing out of oil and gas
even NPR by the way I saw this back in
March had to report that China permitted
more coal power plants last year than
any time in the last seven years and
it's the equivalent of about two new
coal power plants per week everybody
else is moving away from coal and China
seems to be stepping on on the gas one
analyst noted we saw that China has six
times as many plants starting
construction as the rest of the world
combined
so everyone should understand by now if
any Democrat wins in 2024 these U.N
Global emergency Powers will be invoked
as soon as feasible
that means your standard of living will
decline further your freedom of speech
your freedom of worship your freedom of
Association your freedom of movement
will all be limited
our elected officials will hold regular
briefings on the progress being made
they'll insist that the they're just
listening to the science
and just like during covid we're going
to hear from people with long titles
that we need to need to hit our
benchmarks before we can return to
normal again
but of course it won't be the old normal
it'll be the new normal that Obama
hinted at years ago we can't drive our
SUVs and you know eat as much as we want
and keep our homes on you know 72
degrees at all times and then just
expect
that every other country is going to say
okay you know you guys go ahead and keep
on using 25 percent of the world's
energy even though you only account for
three percent of the population and
we'll we'll be fine don't worry about us
it was 2008. now of course none of their
climate rules will ever apply to Obama
living the high life at his mansions in
Martha's Vineyard in Hawaii or they're
certainly not going to apply to
billionaire activists like Bill Gates
who probably runs that AC pretty cool in
Palm Desert
certainly not going to stop Leonardo
DiCaprio from flying private to San
Tropez
we have an emergency all right
we need leaders who have the facts and
the courage to call this U.N power grab
what it is
a complete and total fraud and that's
the angle hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else